Hi, Richard. Good afternoon.
Good morning in Vancouver.
Good morning. It's afternoon here. How are you doing?
Yeah, I'm doing well. How about yourself?
I'm doing great as well. As long as I have my coffee around, I actually have to.
PH.
Are you a coffee person?
Wow, Opus, cute. All right, thank you for joining. I'm going to share my screen so we can start. Let me know once it's available on your end.
Yeah.
Sure.
I'll see your weather there, Richard.
A little bit cloudy today, but not raining. It's warm.
Kip.
It was very hot yesterday, it was 28 Celsius.
28. We normally, the hottest here in the Philippines, 34 degrees.
Yeah, we don't usually get that.
Yeah.
Ohh, that's your highest twenty-eight.
No, you know, in the summertime, we'll get into like 32, 33 kind of thing, but that's not every day. That'll just be like a few days and then it gets cool again. Average temperatures usually around the mid 20s.
20s, wow. Nice to leave. You also have snow, right?
In the summer, yeah. Yeah, in the winter. Well, not really, not Vancouver, because we're right on the Pacific Ocean, right? So the snow is up in the mountains and down at the sea level here. We, if we get any, it might be four or five centimeters in the winter and is gone the next day kind of thing.
But the average temperature in the winter is around 6 to 7 Celsius.
Mm.
Oh my goodness. All right. Good thing you've experienced it. That's my dream though. Anyways, let's start. Richard, this is going to be for our May review. Going on to the agenda items, that's pretty much all the same. For the check-in, this is for you, Richard. How are things at this moment? Would you care to check?
Okay.
OK.
Mhm.
No change. Yeah, all good. No change from last month.
Okay, everything going well with the business?
It, it seems to be, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, have you heard from Zion Works though?
No. There was a little bit of a communications in late April about making a change and then nothing.
So, so everything status quo for now, yeah, status quo for now, yeah.
Maybe they're doing well now.
Oh.
Gotcha. Okay. Thank you for sharing, Richard. For the highlights, I have two for you. So Mark continues to deliver 100% ticket resolution throughout May. That's very good. And he's also helping out with the migration project. So they're still on that. And then Mark demonstrated exemplary punctuality and dedication.
Mhm.
Right.
recording 0 absences, so yeah, his attendance is good lately, 100% compliant, and no tardiness issues.
Good.
Action Tracker, actually, we're still waiting for the survey from you. I can send you an email after this one. I can send you the link. Yeah.
I'm sure.
I did that. I know I did. I clicked on the I clicked on the green happy face.
Oh, yeah, that's for the monthly survey for Mark, and thank you for that. We also have the Q1 NPS survey. So that's the survey for our services to you, the ITBD as a whole, for Q1. But I can send you the link, don't worry.
Ohh.
Okay, all right.
I'll send you after. Thank you. And then...
For performance analysis, these are the IT by design recommended target. You're aware of this, right?
Mmh.
Okay. For the utilization trend, let's see if we are keeping our ITBD target. The May average utilization rate mark closed at 89%. So he hit the target, the 80% target is very good. So I did reach out to him.
Mhm.
And then he mentioned most of his work were focused on projects right now.
OK.
So that's it for ticket closure trend. He's been closing out few tickets lately because as I have mentioned, he's been working on projects, especially the wiki projects. That's for the knowledge base for Zyme Works. He's been working on that lately.
Right.
But if we're going to track the resolution rate, it's been 100%. So whenever he got ticket from a user, he closed it. That's very good. And then even though the ticket closure has been low this month, and that is just because he's been working on a project, that's it.
Good, OK, good.
No other reason.
That's fine, that's fine.
Okay, perfect. IT by Design products, that's Team GPS. You can collaborate with your team, etc. So let us know if you're interested. Same goes with other IT by Design products to build it. Self-managed engineers, if you need workforce, you can let us know. We have co-managed engineers as well.
So Pro Services and Shield IT, just let us know if you're interested. We can help you out. Way forward, we have an upcoming holiday, Richard, that's going to be on June 12th. That's Philippines Independence Day. I would like to ask you if you need more.
Mhm.
Mhm, Okay.
to log in that day or we can have, we can have him take the holiday off. What do you think?
He needs to he needs to ask the local manager if there's anything specific that he needs to be there for that day.
Okay, and that is Kevin?
Kevin, Kevin, yeah.
Okay, sure. I'll let him know and I'll loop you in the email once his manager approved it.
Okay, sounds good.
Okay, perfect. And that's the end of my slide. Richard, anything you want to discuss apart from that?
No, not at this time.
Okay, thank you so much for attending. See you next month, Richard. Have a good one.
Okay.
Bye-bye.